ha Betty is an old working-class
district with the diverse population in
2005 we had a spectacular police raid on
a drug cartel with a helicopter humming
these days it's of residents for artists
and they feel comfortable here they've
always
doesn't equal [ __ ] goof ahalan used to
be a Buster both well this is where
buses were parked repaired and restored
the best / yes
he turns a wicked / [ __ ] can see the
transferred week has two rented studios
we've been in this fantastic venue since
2008 it wasn't easy getting the place
established and now we have 70 students
and hundreds of artists rehearsing here
there's also a dance event where an
artist works with refugees it's totally
international wouldn't was this intense
a lot Jesus classes this street was
built in the late 19th century before
that it was just farmland feels and
swamps by the 1920s it was a real
entertainment district
the hosel van Noy the new residential
buildings had passed apartments in the
front and in the back you'd have the odd
writer Indians i deluded and research
driven begin yet Standish tell next
we'll go to where Robert Musil lived for
a while and where he wrote his novel the
man without qualities links focus on
Shania there used to be a restaurant to
the left of assumptions Thomas anhydrous
man I met here once for dinner it was
evening before Thomas Mann left for
Stockholm to accept the nobel prize for
literature class the literate or house
was founded 30 years ago it has book
presentations and readings from both
German and international or thurs money
might seem a bit old-fashioned but
people like that
so we're on the spree the river that
runs through the middle of Berlin there
are more bridges in Berlin than there
are in Venice there's a lot of clubs
along the screws i have just sprouted up
in the past 10-15 years since the east
side of Berlin became cool again it's
Saturday almost night in Berlin and this
is where it's happening the ELSA sort of
started unofficially six years ago as an
illegal party play I think that a lot of
change in terms of the atmosphere and
the type of clubs that are in Berlin
here it's much more like show up however
you want look however you want do
whatever you want and just have a good
time